Speaker 1: OK, I'm not going to spend a ton
of time on this, but I did want to briefly
play a clip for you that has gone completely
viral. Some of you might remember the film Passion
of the Christ. I didn't see the film. I just don't
care. Passion of the Christ was this movie where
I actually don't remember whether Mel Gibson's
anti-Semitic incident with California police
happened before or after his production
or direction of Passion of the Christ. But
Passion of the Christ, combined with the
anti-Semitic police incident with Mel Gibson,
sort of told us, while Mel Gibson's really
off the deep end, the actor in Passion of the
Christ was right winger Jim Caviezel. Jim Caviezel
appeared at a Q&A on conference over the weekend
and appeared to have a complete meltdown
going into another planet. Jim Caviezel
emulates Braveheart speech to cheering
crowd at on convention, reports Newsweek.
The Passion of the Christ star Jim Caviezel
evoked Mel Gibson's famous battle cry
from the movie Braveheart during a speech at
a Q and on convention in Las Vegas, Nevada.
Caviezel, 53, made reference to the 1995 film
during a speech at the For God and Country
Patriot Double Down Convention. Doesn't that
sound like a fun, family friendly event? The actor
repeated word for word, the famous battle cry.
William Wallace gave to Scottish soldiers ahead
of their do or die battle against the English. He
then added, We must fight for authentic freedom.
It underpinned a speech that
mentioned child sex trafficking,
an issue at the core of QAnon conspiracies, as
well as a fight against Satan and liberal values.
Let's take a look at the video. I would get
the kids out of the room for this one. Here's
Jim Caviezel appearing to lose his mind.
Speaker 6: Will you fight? This man says
no running will live. Yes, but you may die
running. You'll live for at least a while and
dying in your beds many years from now. Would
you have been willing to trade all the years
from this date? And I for one chance.
Speaker 1: This is a very sick person.
Speaker 6: Just one chance to come back here
and tell our enemies that you can take our
lives, but you can never take our freedom. Every
man dies. Not every man truly lives. You, you,
you you. We must fight for that authentic freedom.
Speaker 1: Is he also doing like a slight Scottish
accent in on top of like
Speaker 2: this is crazy
Speaker 6: and live my friends. By God, we
must live with the Holy Spirit is your shield
and Christ is your sword. May you join St
Michael and all the angels in defending God.
Surely Lucifer and his henchmen St.
Louis Farrakhan, where they belong?
Speaker 1: But is that Guccifer, that it was
this was a different speech for a moment.
Reminder, this is the for God and country Patriot
double down. Q event in Vegas this weekend,
Speaker 6: we are headed into the storm of all
storms. There's. This storm is upon us now.
But not without Jesus, our rudder. And in
the words of Reagan, evil is powerless is
to give it a run of faith. God bless you.
Speaker 1: So that's getting a standing
ovation that's considered good by. A
contingent of the American population
that no one would raise questions about a
psych eval in most contexts, number one,
number two, the world sees this and says what
the hell is wrong in the United States right now?
It is a level of wackiness and fanaticism.
And I'm kind of at a loss for words, actually.
Um, and it is a really just kind of scary time. A
little more from the summary. Caviezel ended his
nearly 20 minute long speech by using a term that
features prominently in QAnon lore, and we just
heard that we are headed into the storm of all
storms. Yes, the storm is upon us. QAnon followers
share a belief that former President Trump would
order mass arrests of members of elite cabal
in a day called the Storm. It didn't
happen. They baselessly believe a satanic
cannibalistic cabal made up of celebrities,
Democrat politicians and government officials is
involved in a global child sex trafficking ring.
Oh, this is funny. Cav's, funny. It's horrifying,
but funny. Caviezel previously pushed the QAnon
conspiracy that a chemical compound called
Adrina Chrome is being harvested from trafficked
children. In April, Caviezel told the conspiracy
We should call them conspiracy delusion ists at a
conference in Oklahoma about the untrue conspiracy
while speaking about his upcoming moving sound
of freedom. The movie is based on the life of
self-described anti-human trafficking activist
Timothy Ballard, Caviezel said. When you were
scared. You produce adrenaline. If you're
an athlete, you get in the fourth quarter,
you have adrenaline that comes out of
you. If a child knows he's going to die,
his body will secrete this adrenaline. They
have a lot of terms that they use that he
takes me through. It's the worst horror I've
ever seen the screaming alone, even if I never,
ever saw it. It's beyond and these people
that do it. There will be no mercy for them.
Really, really crazy stuff. Let's just very
quickly look at just a little bit of that. Adrina
Crome. I think this is the key moment you said.
Speaker 7: You said a word
a minute ago, and I want to clarify what
that word was because you said a word.
Yeah. And I want to make sure that you said
Adrina Crum. Yeah, and a lot of people here,
there's about 4500 people here. There's about
a half million people streaming online. Sure,
having some cyberattacks that feeds
been going on and off. It's it's a
cyber. You said that word. And by show of hands,
who's heard that word before in this building?
Could you please explain to the extent that
you want to or not want to know what that is,
because some people have never heard that?
Speaker 1: Yeah,
you may want to keep this a secret,
Speaker 7: Jim, and we need to discuss that.
Essentially, you have adrenaline in
your body. I'll just simplify it. And
and when you are scared, you've produced
adrenaline. If you're an athlete, you get in
the fourth quarter, you have adrenaline that comes
out of you. If a child knows he's going to die,
his body will secrete this adrenaline and
they have a lot of terms that they use that
he takes me through. But. It's the worst
horror I've ever seen is screaming alone,
even if I never, ever, ever, ever saw it.
Speaker 1: OK, so anyway. Completely out
of his mind, guys. There's Jim Caviezel. I
guess you knew new Q and on Hero. Horrible,
horrible stuff. We'll take a quick break
and be right back with much more today